if someone called you scum you'd
probably be offended but scientifically
they might not be far off have you ever
thought about where your food comes from
you might say it comes from plants
animals or even fungi but you'd probably
rather not think about the rotting
organisms and poop that feed those
plants animals and fungi so really you
and most of the matter in your body are
just two or three degrees of separation
from things like pond scum all species
in an ecosystem from the creatures in a
coral reef to the fish in a lake to the
Lions on the Savannah are directly or
indirectly nourished by dead stuff most
of the organic matter in our bodies if
we trace it back far enough comes from
co2 and water through photosynthesis
plants use the energy from sunlight to
transform carbon dioxide and water from
the environment into glucose and oxygen
that glucose is then transformed into
more complex organic molecules to form
leaves stems roots fruit and so on the
energy stored in these organic molecules
supports the food chains with which
we're familiar you've probably seen
illustrations like this or this these
green food chains start with living
plants at their base but in real life
terrestrial ecosystems less than ten
percent of plant matter is eaten while
it's still alive what about the other
ninety well just look at the ground on
an autumn day living plants shed dead
body parts
fallen leaves broken branches and even
underground roots many plants are lucky
enough to go their whole lives without
being eaten eventually dying and leaving
remains all of these uneaten undigested
and dead plant parts that 90% of
terrestrial plant matter that becomes
detritus the base of what we call the
brown food chain which looks more like
this what happens to plants also happens
to all other organisms up the food chain
some are eaten alive but most are eaten
only when they're dead and rotting and
all along this food chain living things
shed organic matter and expel digestive
wastes before dying and leaving their
remains to decay all that death sounds
grim right but it's not all detritus is
ultimately consumed by microbes and
other scavengers
it actually forms the base of the brown
food chain that supports many other
organisms including us scientists are
learning that this detritus is an
unexpectedly huge energy source fueling
most natural ecosystems but the
interactions within an ecosystem are
even more complex than that what a food
chain really represents is a single
pathway of energy flow and within any
ecosystem many of these flows are linked
together to form a rich network of
interactions or food web with dead
matter supporting that network at every
step the resulting food web is so
connected that almost every species is
no more than two degrees from detritus
even us humans
you probably don't eat rotting things
poop or pond scum directly but your food
sources probably do many animals we eat
either feed directly on detritus
themselves like pork poultry mushrooms
shellfish or catfish and other bottom
feeders or they're fed animal
by-products so if you're thinking that
nature is full of waste you're right but
one organisms garbage is another's gold
and all that rotting dead stuff
ultimately provides the energy that
nourishes us and most of life on Earth
as it passes through the food web now
that's some food for thought
you